[Music]
if
protocol is being put in place if a
European super volcano erupts because
scientists are now worried get this
European it's in Italy like Mount vus
like that like Mount vus volcanoes are
scary I didn't even know they had
volcano there yeah they're not respected
the volcanoes in Europe is not
respected they're not a big deal that's
what happened to pomp that was pompe
yeah hundreds of thousands did you see
the pompe
people dying like that they got wrecked
dud yeah I saw it oh [__] yeah there was
one guy that died like this yep is it is
it too it's not too soon to make fun of
those people is it no I think it's been
a couple centuries you could [__]
[__] all over the there's a Pompei guy
that they said the the guy he died
jacking off is that a real thing
apparently
wow hundreds of thousands of people
living in the shadow of a European super
volcano have been warned it could
potentially erupt Italy's campy fi fan
Fields has been displaying some worrying
signs of activity in recent weeks can
you not disrespect the volcano
name I just read what it is can you not
disrespect my hosting I'm you're a guest
be a good one scientists fear the
volcano is a ticking time don't take
that from and say that there is a very
realistic possibility that it could blow
the last time this occurred was nearly
500 years ago wo it's been a long time
maybe it's due I wonder how they tell
those metrics yeah like
pregnancy it's just guesstimation like
you just see a pregnant volcano tummy or
something don't they say the same thing
about Yellowstone how it's like is it is
it a super volcano as well yeah it's
about to blow bro is that a geyser yeah
but I think some volcano underneath it
oh I just heard joean talk about more
than 1100 Tremors have been recorded in
the past month that's
scary a 4.0 magnitude earthquake on the
October 2nd and a 4.2 on September 27th
oh my God all the European like
countries though I feel like Italy can
be one of them that that kind of blows
up like cuz like I don't know I know
shade to it I love their food but how
pretentious they are about their
spaghetti it's annoying man it's too
annoying oh [__] that makes you think
the volcano is going to flow but the
terisu is pretty good though terisu oh
yeah terasu is
sick cars not reliable but fast right um
which one luxury on point design on
point you know but like a little too
pretentious dude like I don't know like
cool it on the pasta right chill like I
If if my pot's small and I want to break
the [__] noodles let me break
it don't be so fussy that part okay yeah
that part they're Pro they're probably
already mad at you cuz you didn't hand
make it cuz every single time you're in
your private home on this side of the
world and you break it they're hitting
you up dude there's a tear dropping an
Italian tiar an Italian Mama
Mia Mama Mia Mama Mia pizzia you're
breaking the goes down for the genocide
of Italians based off of super volcanoes
so this super volcano would take out all
of Italy probably all of it a big chunk
of it uh apparently a pretty big Chun
it'll obliterate Italy why they explain
super volcano and the Damage that it
does a big problem sits west of the city
of Naples and is surrounded by towns and
villages with a combined population of
500,000 they will all die if they don't
evacuate or if they don't have a
protocol set in place and something
happen how serious is this like 10 is
erupting then how serious is this um
they don't have a scale of 1 to 10 but
let me just see if I can dig they can
they just make like a giant ice ball and
then just put it at the top of the
volcano like it cools it down like a
pimple like and it just you know that's
a good idea how about every everybody
take a bucket of ice and throw it in the
hole ice bucket challenge we all we all
that's like a Simpson we go on a line go
on a line everybody do one Buck cool it
down do you think people really do move
when that happens you know like if it's
legit enough but like remember how like
hurricane K Tre to happen and then when
it did everybody was like all the
experts were like this will happen again
because of the shape of the land and the
flooding and the it but then people
still stay they love
Florida I mean Hawaii has an active
volcano Florida but yeah there's an
active volcano right now but people keep
moving to Hawaii I mean I wonder I
wonder what the Italian sentiment is on
it though based off of their own history
with things like Pompei or like knowing
that if you're already living next to a
super volcano it's like maybe there's a
different sentiment they're too they're
too concerned about people making pizza
right and gatekeeping that [__] you have
to focus on the pizza because there's a
volcano they're like the pizza is
crazy forget about the don't worry about
forget about the volcano look at the
pizza I got a fresh slice and and
relative to mount
vus can't be F this volcano actually
dwarf's uh Mount vvus oh my that's a big
statement damn what's m
okay yeah where's that at it's the one
that engulfed Pompei so right next to
pompe okay but that new I love Italian I
[__] love Italian all I'm saying is
if I had to choose between all the
European countries then that's just the
one that's it's okay and you think
they're more pretentious all of the
European well what is yours then
challenge me that is okay
for what are you going to say like
[__] the better sacrifice Estonia or
something o Estonia is nice I know right
blow it up he says country yeah Anthony
Lee said laia under his breath good
that's great that's great we got Lan
fans bro yeah I know shout out to L one
of my one of my good friends grown up
was lan n they don't speak
English
interesting I mean Joe knows all about
the fans I do I [__] like half of them
that's [__] TI half of them fans H so
like if a super volcano explodes Anthony
Lee in the I know it says this is going
to answer my question in the article so
you already know to answer but as soon
as the super volcano explodes how long
until they have they can evacuate cuz it
says it right there right it says the
protocol is a 3-day evacuation for half
a million people and currently uh
schools and stuff like that and
hospitals are already putting into place
like um practices and oh are they so
they're like treating it like as real if
it erupts though that's less than 3 days
if it that's like hours yeah but they're
hope hoping that like their prediction
capabilities will be like oh it's about
to Happ this go for the evacuation it's
currently on yellow alert which is two
levels away from the highest alert
status scary meaning people should keep
an eye on seismic activity and be
prepared for potential evacuation if it
was that bad though do you think all of
Italy would be taken out or just that
area apparently just that area but it
says if it did blow uh we could face a
global winter and subsequent food
shortages Global Winter why is there
food shortage why we yeah why do we get
[__] over dude because like it [__]
up it [__] up the Eco uh like system to
where the sun gets blocked out by the
volcano clouds and and it [__] up the
the temperature and then so the [__]
that you're we could usually grow the
[__] plants are like I'm not used to
this and then they're like I'm not Fring
then but America's okay though right are
we going to get affected by this no this
worldwide oh no we got to stop this are
big enough it could [__] the world a
little I thought this is only going to
affect Italy this is going to affect us
we got to do something you guys weally
together the smoke will come all the way
over here what the [__] I can't get
Italian uh barsley
parsley I I can't get Italian parsley we
got to get the [__] princes of
[__] Saudi Arabia involved we got to
get and we just start WEA machine
unloading sand on the volcano nothing
puts out fire better than
sand put sand they got lots of sand
carry a [__] ton of sand almost
unlimited am bury that volcano with sand
yo that's going to make glass ooh that's
dope they're going to make a glass
Mountain we'll put hammers all over and
the break the glass okay that would be
beautiful I like the first idea I think
if everyone just does a ice bucket
challenge like we just grab all the uh
ice that we can and then we start
dumping it in the volcano it'll cool it
down like a pimple that needs to chill
okay or we could do a preemptive get a
big needle pop the volcano first let it
like you know like a and then squeeze
out the the the the white head yeah and
then it's a little eruption instead of a
big eruption any addons ran to that yeah
let's get Dr pble Popper's
advice how well how well are they able
to predict like volcanos like remember
the one that popped off in the uh Big
Island they didn't predi that sh they're
[__] scary dude those things are when
it's so H they're so predictable when
it's so [__] hot when lava hits water
it's instant steam it's like instant
evaporation it's [__] scary ASU they
say when a super volcano erupts like uh
if if one happened in America for
example like case studies and
Yellowstone which is there is a super
volcano there too if a super volcano for
example Yellowstone were to erupt there
would be it would be a global
catastrophe it would kill around 100,000
people instantly around the area and
make most of North America uninhabitable
as huge amounts of Ash and dust would be
thrown into the atmosphere dude that
insane most of North America were dead
Dam Mother Nature is insane that's
happened before in our history that's
what killed um
kuon the mammoths and stuff is that true
actually um scientists theorized that uh
neanderthals were uh extinct I got a
little Neanderthal on me mhm in My DNA
oh yeah that's right so they haven't
been F Jason chenny like no thank you
thank you that's also cuz we probably
had sex with like I think a human a
neanderthal bent over and they're like o
o I don't care if it's not human and
then they [__] came in it's close
enough right mostly human I mean mean
they're human enough to got smooth
brains right and have a baby unless it's
an entirely different color cuz you
can't really tell right my fils just
have like under bites in our mouth
breathers
yeah I don't know you make it more
prominent as I catch myself like just
breathing on my mouth heavy and then jaw
there's more like o and it feels right
huh like honestly when I'm a deep focus
you just want to scratch the arm a
little when I'm a deep FOC let me tell
you when I'm a deep keep focus on a task
yeah I'll look down and guess what JW
like that really really breathing out my
mouth that's why I wear nasal strips y
yeah but why is the jaw forward more
forward I I have an under well they say
mouth breathing the longer you do it the
more of a underbite you develop really
and they even and this is what Andrew
hubman says and then he says the uglier
you get you get uglier yo yeah what does
that mean I don't know your face shape
starts to change when you mouth breathe
you think people with under bites are
uglier than people with over that's not
what I'm saying but like I could I can't
afford to get uglier bro is what I mean
so that's why I'm wearing like nasal
strips
nowadays that's why huh that's one of
the reasons well you look really cool
when you have them on so thank you but
it's mostly like honestly once I wear
them I can't go back it I can breathe
out my nose I can it huh bro I can smell
y' I sleep with it on me too I S I try
to get deep sleep but what I'm saying is
like throughout the day like a couple
years a well yeah a couple before I
started using nail strips like I I
really can't can't smell most things oh
that well oh do your does your nose feel
more open now now it does wow wait wait
wait this like it feels like someone got
your butt cheeks and spread it open so
you could fart easier no seriously when
you do that with that that you look like
you're wearing those glasses that are
connected to the nose like those
costumes mustache and
[Laughter]
[Music]
eyebrows